welcome to this episode of click to
deploy a series where we show you how
easy it is to deploy solutions from the
google cloud marketplace
in this episode we'll be reviewing how
to set up data bricks via the cloud
marketplace databricks is a cloud-based
data and analytics platform used for
processing and transforming massive
quantities of data
databricks can also be used to explore
the data through machine learning models
and enable teams to use one platform to
collaborate on data analytics and ar
workloads let's start by searching for
data bricks in the google cloud
marketplace we'll choose the first
solution
on the social page please make sure to
read through the overview
pricing documentation and support to
learn more about the solution
pricing for the solution is billed
monthly based on your subscription plan
let's click the subscribe button to
launch the solution you'll notice the
pricing calculator which allows you to
model your estimated monthly cost based
on dbu and time frame
start by selecting a plan we'll choose
the default plan
next choose the correct billing account
agree to the additional terms which are
all about billing and complying with the
license agreement
finally click the subscribe button to
launch the solution
now let's move on to the next step which
is managing our subscription on
databricks you'll need to register with
the databricks account to manage the
solution
sign up or log into your databricks
account
let's create a subscription plan we'll
choose the standard subscription next
let's choose workspaces start by
creating a workspace name let's use the
name test-101
next we'll choose a region
let's choose us west one
and a google project id choose the name
that matches with the project name where
we subscribe to databricks so let's use
test ctd
as you can see our databricks workspace
is running
finally let's test the cluster to see if
it's working
[Music]
there you have it data breaks cluster
deployed with a click of a button if you
enjoyed this episode please subscribe
and hit the like button below we
encourage you to check out the google
cloud marketplace and deploy the
solution on your own thanks for watching
[Music]
you